in Nashville Matt Cox is living it up
while his old girlfriends get used to
prison stripes
Rebecca Hawk has been arrested by the
Secret Service and Allison Arnold is in
prison
Gail McKenzie is the federal prosecutor
in charge of the case there was
absolutely no regard for the over
hundred victims that he left behind his
girlfriend slash accomplices he knew
they had gone to jail he just moved on
with more and more fraud in Nashville
Cox forms yet another fraudulent shell
company steals the identity of another
homeless person and starts dating yet
another pretty young woman a single mom
of course [ __ ] [ __ ] gene Cox born
a worldly mother Phyllis and then griefs
paid for of course with stolen money and
made possible by Cox's stash of fake IDs
you and I can't even get on a plane
without somebody looking at us anymore
Matt Cox you know at the top of the most
wanted list was able to create an ID
that passed muster for him to get out of
the country and back in maybe Coggs has
tempted fate once too often
maybe it's karma catching up with him
but one night is back in Nashville
relaxing at home with his girlfriend
when two armed intruders break through
his front door officer cassandra del
Vasco responds and Cox shows her a video
taken from his security camera you could
actually see one lift his foot up and
kick in the door and one of them told
him at gunpoint and then you see him
getting all their property and you see
Cox's he's kind of mad he's not really
scared he's mad it was terrifying the
thieves get away with the Europe air
fire [ __ ] you [ __ ] got two of what
did you talking about I just kicked in
my front [ __ ] door with with [ __ ]
guns screaming get on the [ __ ] ground
and everything I'm like [ __ ] all I could
think about was what the [ __ ] do you
guys want how do I get rid of these
[ __ ] I thought they were gonna
[ __ ] you know I actually didn't I
think if she said that she said you were
mad when you were kind of explaining it
to them or showing the footage of what
happened you're not after the point I
think it was mad during the flash
definitely I probably looked bad yeah
but I was scared okay
you know you know I'm what the [ __ ] you
know but I just look mad I'm sure but
trust me [ __ ] peer tear our jewelry
and $6,000 in cash [ __ ] files a police
report under his alias and we did run as
DL it was a valid Tennessee driver's
license with this picture on it we had
no reason to believe it wasn't him
that's not good idea around the same
time the Secret Service gets a tip from
a woman in Nashville she's seen the most
wanted poster training's Cox is living
in her neighborhood no tips dirt weight
Trina Trina who's Trina
Trina's the chick that Amanda and I my
girlfriend
the single mother were seeing mMmmm I
remember the first pot Podcast 40 yeah I
remember now Trina Trina a while yeah
yes so Trina Amanda told Trina Trina
calls and turns me in that's her mother
was that they would say the baby's a
babysitter turned him it the babysitters
mother
or the Katrina's mother was the
babysitter she's the one that called
it's just stupid it was trina describes
cops to achieve secret service then gets
in position to make the big arrests and
he's no longer there gone once again
this time we were within two days of him
I can't tell you what a tremendous
letdown that was the day after officer
del Bosco gets a page and I look down on
my computer and I noticed that the
Secret Service had just sent out an
email please stay out of the area we're
looking for a fugitive and I I looked at
the address and I thought hold up a
second we just had a home invasion there
two days ago and I talked to this
supposed to fugitive that they're
looking for working with the Secret
Service
the Nashville police create a ruse they
ask Cox to meet them for a follow-up
report about the home invasion Cox is so
confident in his ability to fool
everyone but he falls right into the
trap
The Secret Service is waiting you are
Matthew Cox aren't you after three years
on the run
Matt Cox is finally stopped he's taken a
total of 12 million dollars from banks
and private lenders and he's left behind
more than 100 victims hmm
once in custody he begins to talk freely
to the Secret Service he was very
forthcoming and what he had done but he
was trying to sell to us just like he
had tried to sell to others that there
really are no victims and that's what he
wanted us to believe that the you know
the title insurance companies that's
what they're there for you know
insurance companies pay policy so really
no one is hurt Bridgette Brown and her
husband were conned by Cox at a time
when they were caring for a sick child
was constantly in and out of the
hospital certainly in our case a young
family going through some stressful
times and he was aware of that you know
we mentioned that getting to the closing
was difficult for us because we had to
find appropriate medical care never
talked to her
till the close I think it was a pretty
poor argument to say that this was a
victimless crime never said it was a
victimless crime till 10 2007
Matthew Bevan Cox pleads guilty to bank
fraud mortgage fraud and I do they even
got this short guy with [ __ ] you know
that's me this is beer oh no that's from
the interview with Dateline that's the
interview with Dateline
his later sentenced to 26 years and no I
gotta watch that again an identity theft
his later sentenced to 26 years in
federal prison this fellow got what he
deserved he got a very stiff sentence in
federal prison and because there's no
parole in the federal system anymore he
is gonna spend a couple of decades plus
you're [ __ ] wrong about that old I've
[ __ ] 26 [ __ ] years for some for some
[ __ ] money
I mean look no offense I'm not saying I
shouldn't have done some time but 26
[ __ ] years are you [ __ ] crazy
that's insane
that's an insane amount of [ __ ] time
yeah depends on who you ask I guess well
I mean clearly to people who might
otherwise be inclined to commit this
type of crime
Rebecca Hawk is sentenced to six years
in prison but she will be eligible for
release in 2009 she got Cox's story has
one more mystery five million dollars of
his loot is still missing
leaving the feds wondering here's the
money
here's the money Maddox million where's
it buried yeah it's uh what do you mean
there's no money bro there's no money
there's no money there's no money it you
know it hurts when you talk to me like
that I have feelings possibilities are
limitless as to where he could have put
the money [ __ ] his former girlfriends
believe he may have an offshore account
if he does it'll be a long time before
he's sipping margaritas on a beach Matt
Cox's projected release date is 2029
here we are in 2020 where's the [ __ ]
money man
[Laughter]